all right guys
bang bang long time coming but finally
eric is here
what uh what's going on man how are you
it's it's a pleasure to be here uh long
time listener first time caller
bang bang is one of the best you know
introductions to a podcast out there
uh glad to be here wait before we get
started can
you got to do the intro to your podcast
guys tweeting at me come on give give us
the quick
intro hey everybody welcome to another
episode of village global adventure
stories
it's the everybody uh accent that uh
that gets people going but you know
that's what people are tweeting
they love it man they love it all right
so for the
the couple of people who are watching
who don't know who you are let's just
start with uh with your background and
kind of what you did before you got to
product hunt
sure so um i'm a venture capitalist and
an entrepreneur i run a venture firm
called village global and i'm chairman
at a company called ondeck
the the back story is i um i grew up in
new jersey i'm a son of israeli and
colombian parents
i went to university of michigan started
my first company uh read a college
called rapt fm
it was like zoom or or chat roulette for
for rap battles we're trying to be
twitch for music
started with rap battles uh resolving a
personal
interest and um did that for about three
years uh
we had some traction but it was just
early in the in the live video space
and so um it uh it didn't take off
but uh learned a lot uh through that
experience i met ryan hoover
who was the founder of product hunt and
uh when i was leaving rapt i asked him
hey can i can i help out can i can i i
think that i thought that helping him
out would be the best way to figure out
what i wanted to do next
and so i uh joined him uh i offered to
work for free he said no
i'll pay you but my job title was
hustler
so i was a hustler at product hunt and
within
six months it had you know gotten into y
combinator then raised six million
dollars from addressing
and then i said well i guess this is the
next thing i'm doing for a while
and uh after uh product was a two plus
year journey
fantastic uh journey and i i left uh
right before i left i started on deck
which was a
uh dinner series for event series for
people who are looking to start or join
their next thing
and exterior there was basically i
started angel investing while i was at
product
because i was just building my my
network like crazy seeing all these
deals sending to investors i said hey
i should start investing too so i
started angel investing i started scout
investing
and i realized that product was just
this unfair advantage this asset
that i could have to discover deals and
then to get into deals
and i wanted to build more unfair
advantages or assets like i'm not the
the smartest person in the world i i
need to have uh
you know i don't have other superpowers
i need to have these these assets and so
i thought if i you know products and
helps people with customers if i could
help people recruit or find co-founders
that would be an unfair advantage too so
i started on deck event series later
became a
you know 10-week fellowship and and
we'll go into and i was trying to be a
new university and then i said
what would a venture firm from the
ground up built uh built from the ground
up with the idea of unfair advantages
look like and that's when i teamed up
with ben casanoca and anne duane
and created a network driven venture
firm village global which is 100 million
dollar
seed stage uh venture fund all right so
let's go to
product hunt first uh if anyone is
paying attention to the tech industry
they
they've heard of product hunt they've
seen product hunt they've probably tried
to get to the top of product hunt kind
of all these things
uh you were um very early i think even
maybe
employee number one uh talk a little bit
about like
you saw a company that not only scaled
and ultimately exited to
angel list but also a company that was
right in the heart of silicon valley
like you had
all those deals you had all those
products coming to you guys like what
were the biggest
lessons learned or takeaways for you
personally
as you saw that business get built and
help really helped scale it to what it
became
yeah there's a few lessons one in terms
of getting the job in the first place
um there's this idea that young people
are especially
scared to just start um
because they if they will be a blemish
on their resume would be uh it's it's
something to be proud of and there's a
difference between
job risk and career risk job risk is the
risk that your job is there two years
from now career risk is the risk that
that it sets you back whereas being a
founder actually uh it
it it shows to other people that you
know what it's like to be uh
to be an entrepreneur that you know how
to recruit you know how to
sell you know how to take risks and so
um you know one thing also a young
person especially if you funded
something
you don't necessarily sell hey look at
all the things that i've done uh you
know
in my life sell your slope look at all
the things i've done the last two months
look at all the things i've
done the last two weeks in the last year
i started here and here's where i got to
and uh ryan in seeing that it you know
this sort of entrepreneurial spirit in
me that was able to
handle ambiguity uh that was a lesson
learned in terms of that's why i think
people should be
more ambitious and more willing to take
what i call asymmetric risks
uh that's what i took while i was a
product of this idea that your downside
is capped you know if product didn't
work out i would have still built this
incredible network
um but the upside is is uncapped if if
it was you know if it turned into this
monster business i would have meaningful
upside in it so one lesson
is pursue asymmetric risks learn how to
sell yourself with slope and then the
other is
i knew that i wanted to be an investor
and
um you can't really if you're getting
into the game you need to have some
reason
why people want to take your money over
this you know sea of other
uh investors out there and so being able
to have an
asset or a structure that really helps
them
uh recruit or get customers
or raise money uh that is sort of
independent from your time i mean
product was this asset where i was
giving
or helping give you know dozens of
founders
game changing traction every single day
there like there's
there's nothing that that can be in my
sleep and so
i for advi uh aspiring investors out
there i really encourage them to think
about
what are other assets and maybe it's you
know it's a podcast like
like your podcast maybe it's an event
series maybe it's a conference maybe
it's a forum maybe it's some digital
product that really just gives you
gives you an edge and so when you think
through that
uh i think people now say like oh
no-brainer eric's so smart like look at
all the things that he's built to give
him those edges
uh i'm assuming that while at product
hunt you saw
people build uh lots of things some that
were some that didn't work
any frameworks or kind of mental models
that you came up with to kind of think
through
um what actually was truly sustainable
and and kind of gave advantages versus
maybe things that
uh they were shiny toys and would you
know be popular on product hunt for a
day or two but ultimately would kind of
fizzle out
like you i feel like you just got a lot
of reps in terms of not having to build
the compass you just saw them and any
lessons learned there
yeah if you think everyone in terms of
sort of like building this edge or
building
assets uh in the same way that i like
the idea of
seeing your career as a product and
focusing too many people
try to network right away without
thinking about how to
trying to get coffee with somebody
without thinking about how do i add so
much value when i get coffee with that
person especially they'll want to keep
having coffee with me or add me to their
network and that that's the hard part
like finding
pomp's email is not the hard part it's
being getting in his rotation
having something to to add and so in the
same way that
products and companies think about
building moats i advise that people
think about building personal notes so
you know
your personal mode should be unique to
your talents and interests something
that's easy for you to do
but hard for others something that
compounds over time
and something that's hard to reverse
engineer hard for other peoples to do
so some examples i give you tyler cowan
has encyclopedic brain
uh and the intersection of economics and
politics and history
and you see him talk and you think wow i
would have to
probably spend a couple decades to get
to get to where he's at another example
is
elod gill who's invested probably in a
couple dozen unicorns
angel investigators are investing in
this interesting sort of inefficient
market where
uh it takes many years to be seen as
good
even if you you know uh so if you start
right away you won't
you won't know until you're good until
for seven years from now so for each for
someone to
match elod's unicorn account again
probably have to spend a
couple couple decades and then and then
you pump building your audience
over many years a very loyal audience
for someone to say how do i become pomp
i don't know that's a really hard thing
to do and you want to build a personal
mode that that when someone's like how
do i reverse engineer this
they don't even know where to begin and
so for you
uh obviously you learned a lot of this
at product hunt you saw people try
things what worked what didn't work
uh ultimately when you went to start uh
on deck talk a little bit about
um kind of what that original idea was
uh
and then it's really evolved over time
right it kind of started out as this
dinner series or event series
uh and now has very ambitious plans but
let me talk just about like what
pulled you guys in that direction as you
said so
one thing i really learned from from
ryan is pursue side projects because
you never know what they can turn into
product started for a side project
ryan's
documented how it was just an email list
and then turned into a company
on deck 2 was a side project i was
looking for my next co-founder it's
actually kind of hard to find a
co-founder people say oh it has to be
someone you met in college or
someone you someone you worked with but
um there's a lot of potential
people out there and so i started this
event serious to solve my own problem
which is how to find a co-founder and
then if what i found is if you go down
to your dropbox facebook airbnb
stripe all these companies and ask their
sort of talented people like
do you think in the next year you might
want to start a company and might you
want to be in a community to meet other
potential co-founders
nearly all of them will say yes it's
just it was sort of an underserved
opportunity so we started doing these
one-off events it was a volunteer
community for for a couple of years we
had
sort of you know 5 000 people attend
events in dozens of cities around the
world
all volunteer run and then what we
realized is that
we weren't necessarily having the
compounding benefits that we wanted like
someone in 2016
didn't have an easy way to connect to
someone in 2018 and that's when we
really started the fellowship which sort
of this accelerator model this cohort
model
we started last year we've now had five
of them and um
accelerators are just so powerful for
creating uh creating long-term community
compounding benefits it gets stronger
the the more people that that enter it
and
we said to ourselves hey we really know
how to do fellowship for
for founders we then we're about to
start this angel fellowship
but we realized like hey we're not just
going after stanford mba we're going
after stanford and so
that's the vision is to sort of be a
digitally native you know university
as if it was started in 2020 especially
in the era of covid and so we say if
stanford is trying to
teach people how to be citizens of
functioning society we're trying to help
people become
functioning citizens of the internet and
what is it what do you need to be a
functioning citizen of the internet well
you might want to start a company you
might want to build an investment
portfolio
you might want to write you might want
to have a podcast you might want to
build an audience
so that's that that's our grand vision
and it's the thought process that
basically
uh it's kind of like a um futuristic
school
where literally like i i sign up and i'm
with a class and i literally learn from
teachers or kind of talk a little bit
about like what does that
experience look like for people who are
participating yeah so imagine you so our
founder fellowship
is is like a y combinator or a village
global accelerator experience
but before you have a company so you're
looking for a co-founder you're looking
for startup ideas
or you really just want to be in that
sort of accelerator ecosystem without
giving up equity
we we we charge a fee and that's how we
make money um
and so imagine that model the
accelerated model applied to
uh for angel investors for for writers
for
podcasters for youtubers for designers
for product managers
so what makes that experience powerful
is a few things so one is
you guess speakers from from top
practitioners two is the sort of
group experience and accountability so a
lot of people who are going to our
writers program
they really just want to have this
regular cohort what why i see the other
accelerators that coach do so well is
every week
you have to come and share what you've
done what you've shipped
and that public accountability that some
people say that's like the best part
part
of the accelerator is really just week
after week in front of very smart people
that pressure puts uh puts positive
pressure on you to
to chip and just get things done so
people really appreciate the cadence
and then just up leveling the game the
same way you might go to fitness boot
camps to see other people
who are you know beating your butt and
now oh i have to really step up my game
and then uh coming out with a finished
product at the end so
we really think about how can we
accelerate people's goals and then
you start to build positive network
effects so you know the first cohort of
y combinator ever
was justin khan alexis ohanian sam
altman right they would go on to do
incredible things together
and they would benefit from the
following cohorts that would one make
the credential more impressive so going
yc
is this impressive thing but then also
they'd be able to hire those people
invest in those people team up with
those people and especially in sort of
the covet era
community is scarce and so
uh the power of a fellowship to provide
that ongoing community that just gets
stronger
is uh is really working for us got it
what's the biggest challenge with
building
the company right so you guys have kind
of grand plans
and things have gone well and you
started to scale the business what are
the biggest things that keep you and the
rest of the team up at night
we want to get to dozens of fellowships
in in the next year we see kovid as
the biggest opportunity uh where people
are just eager to have community
eager to have uh fun things to do that
are meaningful uh
and um and the opportunity cost is is of
their time is much lower
and so we're blitz scaling uh we were
you know i think one million uh you know
run rate in may
now we're five we were probably eight
people in may
now we're 21. uh we'll do dozens of new
fellowships we'll probably
you know quadruple the team in the next
you know uh year
and so uh learning how to scale when we
haven't scaled before
is uh is the biggest thing on our mind
and but how to keep the quality high
uh while you're doing it got it and then
when a lot of people look at this i
think that they'll say
uh this is a fantastic business in terms
of
all of the ancillary benefits but how do
you think of it as a
business right what i mean by that is uh
is this something that looks more like
an events business and you know kind of
a
exit opportunity is there is it
something that looks like
um you know consulting or teaching or
education like
you know part of the beauty of some of
these businesses they don't fit in the
box but when you when you kind of think
through it like
where do you put it or how do you think
about the intersections of maybe some of
these disciplines and what you guys are
doing
yeah this business has really actually
humbled me as an investor
because it broke all the rules in terms
of what you're not supposed to fund
so a chairman with the majority
ownership of a company who's not
full-time
who it was a volunteer thing for for a
couple years in sort of this weird space
it's unclear if it's a technology
business if it's a services business
so many vcs passed on this business for
all the right reasons um
and it just turns out you know that it's
working it's still early of course
but in terms of how we see it as a very
big business the founder fellowship
alone
is a five million dollar business so two
thousand uh
uh uh 2500 people a year will pay around
two thousand dollars
to be a part of this program uh we think
that we could do dozens of fellowships
they're also multi-million dollar
businesses on themselves
and then we think once we've done a lot
of fellowship businesses
we can do a fellowships as a service
product where we can enable other people
to sort of build you know passionate
communities almost many cults
around themselves and giving them the
tooling and infrastructure to
to do that for you there's a sort of
saying that social networks are
you know come for the tool uh stay for
the network like uh
tiktok and uh instagram or musically but
others are
come for the network and stay for the
tool or data that that network can
generate
so product is one class example linkedin
is another
example quora is another example and i
think we're doing something pretty
interesting here too where if you have
you know tens of thousands of founders
of writers
podcasters like why couldn't we compete
with sub stack
uh you know what's defensible about
substack is the relationship with the
writers but we're going to have these
incredible relationship writers
so that as a platform for different
technology businesses that you could
build on top of it
is is what gets me really excited but
even still from the services business
the fellowships
is what allows us to hire to scale we're
profitable
we don't need to raise any more money uh
at least that's the plan right now
and um and we and the reason why i think
people are willing to pay
right now partially because we've we've
sort of established a strong community
and these businesses are very hard to
disrupt like
once you have a y combinator once you
have an accelerator that has you know a
few courts under its belt and people
love it it just
it's very hard to compete with um and in
the coveter that people are willing to
pay they maybe have more money because
they're
doing less other things um that uh we
think we could
bootstrap a lot of these uh cohorts in
different categories
got it and so obviously you've taken a
lot of these lessons around building
moats and advantages
uh into the venture space with village
global
um you have uh probably one of the most
impressive lists of lps
uh you've told the story before but kind
of give us the the 60 seconds on just
how the lp list came together uh
whatever names you're able to share
publicly and then we can talk a little
bit about the actual model that you're
employing
sure so so we asked early on how do we
build unfair advantage
or a network at every level of the
firm's dna
and so uh part of that was the lp base
uh where
you know ben kasinoka uh is a former
chief of staff
to to read hoffman and is just uh
amazing
at working with with reed and other uh
luminaries
and us three comb combined with reed and
a couple others
were able to sort of paint a picture of
of what
sort of a new allen company could could
look like a new allen company
meets a meets a y combinator and sort of
sell them uh
you know mark zuckerberg jeff bezos bill
gates and their
their teams a vision that this was going
to be really strategic for them that we
were going to have
like a y combinator we're going to have
hundreds of startups a year that could
be potential partners for them
potential acquisition targets for them
uh and just keep them sort of
fresh on what what the latest and
greatest is in in venture
and so it was really a combination of
luck and then selling them a vision that
this was
this more than any other venture firm
was going to be a one could be
successful
but two could be a really strategic
asset for for for insights and network
intel
and at when they're at that stage in
their career obviously sort of the
incremental dollar
is not as important as as the
incremental edge that can help
you know facebook or amazon or or
microsoft uh
so with that that was one unfair
advantage we thought about was the lp's
and we spent a year and a half
uh working with the various teams to to
make that happen and then we also
thought
how could we really decentralize venture
so we had this thesis that
um ventures way too centralized sort of
this irony that venture capitalists
are supposed to be capitalists to sort
of operate their business like they're
socialists
like it's one central planner saying
this is what the price of bread is i
know it better you know across every geo
across every sector across every network
and we just saw that there's this
explosion of complexity that there
aren't just
you know one person used to be able to
cover the entire internet john door you
should just clean up right
but now you don't have to sub sectors
like crypto you have sub sectors and sub
niches within
like privacy coins and define all these
different areas of expertise
and and networks that are cropping up
that there's no way
that five people on san jose could be
masters of universe and have expertise
in all of them
and that you need to decentralize uh
power
decision making to the people who have
the most knowledge and so we have this
network
of 30 plus angel investors that we
empower with our capital
such that they can uh express their
local expertise and
whether their key network or key sector
or key geography
and make investments on our behalf got
it
and so as you've built this out
obviously um
you guys have had a lot of a success
finding companies very early
is that mainly dependent on kind of this
scout-like network where those
individuals have that industry domain
expertise or experience and
they're kind of finding it and you guys
are using that system
or these things where maybe you've built
other systems or advantages where you're
getting
some sort of deal flow so early right on
deck as an example or other things like
just talk a little bit about um it's one
thing to find good companies or to find
good founders it's another to find them
before they've started a company or
literally you know in the early days
of the starting of the company not
waiting till the series a or later
and yeah a lot of it is competition over
who can get there first and who can add
value to the entrepreneur such that
they're the first person they go to
when they're fundraising because it's as
you know it's incredibly competitive
market
so it's a few things it's it's the scout
network that is
out there we have scouts that are
embedded in different companies that we
think have
have you know strong mafias and looking
for the best people to come out of there
uh that own some of our scouts own
specific conferences or
have specific assets uh themselves that
enable them to
to uh be first call and and one key
thing that we do relative to other
venture firms is
we empower them to make the decision
often without our uh
you know our screening it so the we by
decreasing the friction
they can uh they feel more empowered to
work with us than to send it to
some other firm but then also you know
as i mentioned
unfair advantages not just in being able
to to to win the deal
but also in being able to evaluate one
thing i mean at the earliest stage
so much of it is people bet and one
thing we like to do is is yeah put them
in on deck let's see them
over how they work over ten weeks or
three months what do they ship
who do they team up with uh how do they
engage in the community
you know we've pulsed the community for
who are the most compelling
entrepreneurs here
and that just extra data uh gives us an
advantage
when we decide to pull the trigger or
not relative to uh another firm seeing
you know seeing them for the first time
and and that time is accelerated i think
first round had this stat
that a few years ago it used to be 90
days between the first
uh touch point and term sheet and now
it's nine days
so these processes are so competitive
founders are often going to other angel
investors or founders before they go to
vcs and by the time they go to vcs it's
sort of like ycdemo
is this bidding auction so obviously
every investor wants to avoid the
bidding auction
talk a little bit about uh what you're
seeing with
investment round dynamics so you just
talked a little bit about timeline going
from 90 to 9 days
talk maybe about the idea of
firms versus angel investors versus kind
of the solo capitalist trend
and then also what you're seeing in
terms of check sizes right you know if
you talk to somebody
from angel list they would say hey it'll
empower somebody to invest and then kind
of syndicate the rest of the deal if you
talk to
an investor who's got kind of a very
large capital pool they'll say
you know we're trying to take out entire
rounds or whatever so kind of what are
you seeing at the earliest stages of
investing that
might not be as obvious to those who
aren't in the trenches doing this every
day
yeah a few things one i have this
broader belief
in that it's individuals not
institutions
and that people always and that's not
just in venture but it's in um
it's in media it it's in a variety of
different industries that people just
identify with the authenticity
of a specificity of an individual verse
versus institution and it you sort of
ask why has it been that way well it's
sort of it's always been that way but
now
individuals are just more empowered than
ever as you know as you've covered in
this podcast
to have direct relationships with their
audience to be able to monetize directly
from from their audience
and you can sort of cut uh you know and
it's just it's just so much easier to
create a living and create an audience
uh individually and that that's no
exception
uh in venture that's why you're seeing
so many people go it alone so many
people prefer
to take money from operator angels or
solo gps
they can just move faster they have more
specificity to them
and i i think it relates to this broader
trend within venture which is the
decentralization adventure
instead of uh this is prediction for the
future of entry instead of
you know a couple dozen people on a cap
table you should have hundreds
or or a thousand and in that way you
could really unbundle
the capital with with advice and get
some people who are world class
in different positions sort of this is
the increasing specialization and thus
uh decentralization and we're already
starting to see it i'm seeing a lot of
firms
just open up space for small checks you
know we just had a company
um that is uh doing a he was raising a
monster around
and he's leaving a million dollar it's
one of those competitive rounds in the
valley but leaving a million dollars
for for their audience and doing it on
on we funder so
um i think we're gonna we're already
seeing the sort of rise of individuals
over institutions and i think we're
gonna see a lot more
individuals coming onto cap table now
for sure this is at the earliest
stages is that seed at you know
at a at b these individuals don't don't
have the capital yet
but i think we'll start to see solo
capitalists uh
go later stage as well and so explain
maybe the psyche
uh of an uh founder who says hey you
know i have a really hot round a bunch
of investors are all fighting over
getting in
but i'm gonna save this million dollars
for uh that audience
or the user base is it simply i want
them to have some feeling of ownership
and that will lead to more usage and
they'll go kind of be
ambassadors for me is it something else
like why why would they do that
this concept of value add or even
founder friendly it's a
it's a cliche now but it's a fairly new
construct and it's telling in the sense
that
venture didn't need used to sell
themselves to founders
founders begged them to take their money
but then capital became a commodity
and more people started to have it you
started to have a little bit of
unbundling between capital
and value-add and so now people really
need to to
differentiate and it's still incredibly
inefficient
the people can often add the most value
to your business often other
entrepreneurs
uh other execs they don't have the cap
they're not leading the series they
like investors are uh usually
generalists they're rarely
the person that can offer the most value
for your company relative to the stake
that that that they take up and so if
you're building
a community product or a product uh that
really relies on evangelists
you know one of our companies rome uh is
is incredible
uh sort of productivity uh product a
personal
knowledge management product and has
their own cult and
for a community like that who's so
invested in it also to feel
uh more invested via via ownership uh is
just very powerful
in in expanding its its moat and i think
part of the dynamic is
sort of questioning hey you know vc's
what value are you really adding
relative to the people who can
evangelize your product and this was
something that like crypto
it was trying to do with tokens you know
ways to disrupt these sort of network
effects businesses
is just incentivizing orders of more
magnitude people to use your product
and to identify with it and want to see
it grow
so one of the interesting trends for me
uh not only is one the social capitalist
thing obviously but but two is this idea
that
uh many times founders or other
operators are the most helpful
uh today they don't have the capital
like you described but
it doesn't seem a stretch to me for
those people to eventually
have very large pools of capital and you
know do you see a world where
um you know there's been a couple of
companies that have raised rounds where
there's been no institutions right it's
been all individuals
um and quite large rounds or we're not
talking about a you know half million
dollar round we're talking about
literally tens of millions of dollars
like is that a trend that is
accelerating or
are those kind of outliers and you know
they're cool to talk about but
they probably won't become the norm over
time yeah
i um generally i abide by the rule of
whoever owns the customer demand
gets to capture the value and
founders would rather work with other
successful founders
than vcs on average and right now um
there's you know every industry is held
back by regulations
and and ventures is no different
one of them is that vcs have
long vesting schedules such that it's
very difficult to to switch you know you
saw when keith for boy joined founders
fun when sarah table
joined benchmark there was a sort of
question of like is this about to become
nba free agency this is like kevin
durant you're going going to the
warriors
and the answer for right now is no
because the vesting contracts are just
too long such that they're giving too
much
to to do that but i expect i expect gps
because they capture the value more so
than the institutions um
that they work at if their stars will be
able to renegotiate
those contracts such that they're more
fairly flexible
and then also accreditation of course
prevents many uh
you know entrepreneurs or many execs
from being able to
being able to invest um but i think this
is a
a trend that will only continue is right
now held back by
by certain regulations or or practices
but once
sort of value capture reorients to the
value creation which sort of inevitably
uh happens even if it's a slow process i
think we'll continue to see it
you've talked before about generational
theft uh and this idea that uh
it seems like everyone's becoming a
socialist
[Laughter]
and uh i've talked about it from like
every capitalist on wall street in time
of crisis becomes a socialist right and
everyone's looking for bailouts
all this crazy stuff yeah i think you're
talking about something a little bit
different maybe
describe a little bit what you mean
there by generational theft and
relationship to socialism
yeah well i i want to first say that one
reason i'm so excited to build a new
university right now
is because universities are just in a
really tough place
and i think that they are sort of
ripping off their their customers
i mean think about an industry that has
increased you know 300
in terms of cost since 1980 without any
verifiable
increase in quality college debt is now
1.7 trillion dollars
uh it's kind of like a ponzi scheme we
have a federal loan program funded by
the taxpayer so students go into debt
and then keep paying taxes to fund other
people's debt
uh and then that's just the financial
situation in terms of the product itself
colleges use we used to sort of
outsource uh iq test and conscientious
test
to colleges such that they were good
filters of talent but now we're getting
rid of the sat we're getting rid of the
gre
we're getting rid of all these
standardized testing so it's unclear
what it actually means to get into a
university anymore
on top of that professors are miserable
they're
underpaid students are in tremendous
debt and all of this
is separate from kovid which is sort of
shown that the emperor has no clothes
and that people are still paying the
same amount of money for zoom university
it just shows that you're really just
paying for the piece of paper
and which we said if they you know stop
serving as a good filter talent it's
unclear what that piece of paper
is going to mean and and that sort of
begs the question
how can they operate this way and it's
because without any competition there's
been no
university that's cracked the top 10 in
over 100 years and that was stanford
any other industry that has terrible you
know product for its customers
or just costs way too much you get
competition and it's because it's a
cartel basically
it's a government-enforced monopoly that
where they run the accreditation process
which allows them to sort of give
federal uh
loans uh federal subsidies uh it
tax shelters on a operating level and on
an endowment level i mean
harvard has a 40 billion dollar
endowment that's that's a tax cut hedge
fund
so we talk about generational theft and
socialism part of it is education
in terms of the average person i believe
in 29 000
of debt but the you know nearly half of
americans have under 2
000 liquid assets so yeah and this debt
is not
dischargeable in bankruptcy so that's on
education
on housing we have a massive structural
shortage between
2017 you went from about 11 million
units of low income housing
to about 7 million every year you're
seeing 330 000 units of affordable
housing uh shortage
there's something like 17 million people
who can't afford housing right now so
that's education that's housing and then
it's healthcare like i said
people have like under two thousand
dollars in liquid assets and yet
deductibles for individuals are like
fifteen hundred dollars so any health
issue
you have it means you're basically
financially ruined and so it's it's no
surprise that when somebody says the
system has screwed you
to young people uh and we the government
are gonna fix everything
whether it's you know the right-wing
sort of populism of trump or the
left-wing populism of bernie or even
elizabeth warren it's no surprise that
people people resonate with that
because uh you know what's the point of
capitalism if you can't acquire any
capital if you can't
you know get a house if you can't get
health care if you you can't pay for a
good education
so that's why people are so so skeptical
about it and it's it's the worst time
for that to happen
well i also think what's really
interesting is uh
if you look at um some of the
non-financial metrics like i saw stat
today that said between the ages of uh i
think it was
18 and 29 i believe for the first time
since the great depression anyone
between the age of 18 and 29
52 or over 50 percent now live at home
with their parents
yeah and and i was just like look you
know
there's the kind of cliche oh the
millennials live at home you know all
that kind of stuff
uh obviously there's data that's
supporting some of this what we don't
know is how many of those people
are coveted you know they let at least
expire they move home with their parents
and then they'll move out you know maybe
the start of the year or whatever
but we i think you you get to is uh
there is a
very different relationship with
capitalism with money with assets with
you know buying a house all of these
things that
uh i think are kind of like memes um in
terms of people talking about them
but they're funny and they resonate
because they're true right
and that's basically what you're
describing here is um there's almost
this like self-reinforcing system that
uh guides people on this journey between
the ages of
you know i don't know 10 years old and
30 years old and very few people kind of
recognize
hey there's traps along the way and i
love your framework of like the
asymmetric career risk
right and so what i guess what are the
attributes of the people that you see
uh maybe break out of that you know
track that they're on or kind of what
are the things that you see people do
whether they're actions or maybe
some sort of attribute that does allow
them to realize hey wait
this isn't the only path in life there
is something else that i can go do
yeah the um and just to put a bow on
your point millennials were told that
they'd be better situation
than their parents financially and
they're not they're living with their
parents and they see their parents doing
much better
and so that's sort of the generational
theft is this this lie that they see
of of of what they envisioned was this
was this american dream
and so now they now they blame the
system especially when other people are
are providing them you know with sort of
well i think our faulty solutions
or recommendations in terms of people
who who get out of it well first it's
it's don't walk into the traps to begin
with
now if you can get into harvard i'm not
gonna necessarily tell you
not not to get into harvard but if
you're going to some third-rate
university
and about to take out quarter million
dollars in debt maybe reconsider that
think about why you're going in the
first place think about and
the the crazy thing about the university
is that there's also this sort of
um anti-well capitalist bent
at the university and so um not
everywhere but in a lot of places in a
lot of departments so
you go to the university you get quarter
million dollars in debt and then you're
told that the reason you're a quarter
million
debt is capitalism's fault when
capitalism is the thing that's going to
get you out of the debt
so you're both like financially ruined
and also like
sociologically um you know just less
likely
to produce a big outcome if you think
you know or to get out of that debt in
in a flourishing way if you think
capitalism is the is the enemy
i i think there's this new movement
called progress studies that tyler cowan
and patrick collison have have started
alongside others jason crawford who are
picking up the work
and what they're really doing is they're
when they're trying to fight back
on the university level in terms of
providing viewpoint diversity
it's great it's great to have multiple
perspectives including
the one that exists currently but then
also what they're really focusing on is
retelling the story of basically
how did we get such a better standard of
quality of life
how did we get billions of people out of
poverty uh and the answer is basically
markets uh you know uh uh capitalism and
so
by sort of creating this this
appreciation for
for for for for capitalism for for
markets for for the power to
get people out of poverty to invent new
things to to change people's lives
i think so one way i see people doing is
is really appreciating the the tools
that are going to get out on an
individual level
but then also being able to tell the
story that once they get out an
individual level
i mean see all the great things that
people like bill gates and
and elon musk are able to do for for
society uh that they can
you know uh not not just help themselves
but also uh
help society at large where do you see
the biggest
opportunity for young people today right
so uh young people
are uh in this situation uh kind of from
a generational standpoint
um is it to go into tech and build
companies to go work for technology
companies like
if you're you know 17 years old 18 years
old you're graduating high school what
is that blueprint that you think
uh is just the better way yeah so
you know what's interesting about crypto
in 2016 2017 when it was really popping
off
and you see a lot of the the funds that
emerged out of it or even just the
people who were leading a lot of the
projects
is a lot of them were were young people
were people in their 20s
people who didn't necessarily have a lot
going on beforehand
and that's not because they're smarter
or because they're more accomplished
they're not um in fact but the reason
was was that
they were more comfortable taking
asymmetric risk because
crypto looked stupid you know like
bitcoin looked dumb
uh before it now we sort of you know
normalize it we have all the industry
around it you know but
it it really was the career risk for for
people
uh and this is where i go back to job
risk and career risk the less you have
going on
the more you should be willing to take
asymmetric risks because
one you're only known for the things
that you succeed at not the things you
fail at
i i failed at rapt fm a week later i was
at product hunt no one
cared anymore and no one's cared ever
since reid hoffman
mark mark andreessen immensely
successful people reed hoffman started a
social network dating site that was a
total failure social net no one knows
about it
mark andreessen started ning a social
network for dogs like
total failure no one knows about it so
you're known for your successes
and you want to take big swings you
really have very little to lose
if you're in an okay financial situation
um and um
and a lot to gain so so crypto was that
in 2016 2017
today what is that what what what looks
dumb but if it works could be enormous
i'm really intrigued by income share
agreements there's a community that's
working in charter cities that that you
know
building startup societies that that's
incredibly difficult but could be
enormous
uh virtual reality is always just just
around the corner
so um whether it's starting something or
joining something
i i would look for where are things that
other people think are dumb but you
don't think are dumb because that's
where that's where the that's where the
arbitrage is um i would join something
like on deck or
y combinator or village global
accelerator i would try to put yourself
in networks such that
even if your startup doesn't work you've
just built this incredible network
um but yeah nothing is uh better than
than doing
in terms of in terms of learning so if
you don't have to be
in college and you don't particularly
want to be and and
you're compelled by the idea of
potentially starting a company there are
communities out there for you that will
support it and i would recommend it
uh geographies to do all of this um you
have
spent a good portion of your career in
san francisco uh
long or short san francisco and then uh
where
else if uh would you be long on so this
is the um
the best time to live anywhere i i i i
sort of talk about living on the
internet you know
we used to say it was it was never less
important to to live in san francisco
but you had more important to
to be connected to san francisco and a
few years ago you had to be in san
francisco
but now most of us are living on the
internet
most of us don't even know where we are
when we communicate each other most of
our communication is online
so it's less that san francisco
decreases in power or the
rest rises in power it's just that
location matters less and less together
physical location especially as
companies go more remote because they've
learned how to do it
recently um and what i'll be really
excited about this is that
it's it's an equalizer you don't have to
move to san francisco or go to harvard
to get your education grow your network
or or build your
build your reputation you you want to be
at the
the locust point of where all the
activity is now by all means if you can
move
sure go to san francisco san francisco
great but you don't necessarily
have to what's more important is what
group chats are in
who you follow on twitter and who who
follows you what what telegram chats
you're in
what does your digital ecosystem uh look
like and you can do that for from
anywhere
so i asked for questions from people on
twitter and they sent
a whole list of obnoxious ridiculous
questions uh i chose my favorites
um and i figured we could do some rapid
fire and you just
throw out answers as we go uh the first
is
um i think on a 20-minute vc episode you
talked about from no one to vc
in that path uh what is the blueprint
for somebody who
is literally a nobody nobody knows who
they are uh but then they can
very quickly break into venture capital
yeah so the
the first thing uh and this is sort of
contrary to what
people want you to think is uh you have
to get numbers on the board
you have to start writing tracks and
checks and building a track record
and it's because vc is incredibly
inefficient asset class
um you know it takes seven to ten years
to be great and not just because of the
skills that you gain but just because of
the feedback loop to even know how
you're doing
you can invest for two three years go in
a coma for seven years
come back out and be one of the best
investors in in the world
there's no other industry where that's
the case um and
and vc's so reflexive where if if you're
known to be the best then you get better
deals
and so uh you it just sort of becomes
true and so
you need to to build that early in in
basketball for example you could find
lebron james at 18 and realize oh my god
this person's not only going to be
incredible but incredible
right now and can dominate it's obvious
the vc there's no v
equivalent of a young person yeah maybe
they have a network and stuff but you
don't really know if they're good at
picking
for for years so uh my advice to people
want to get into it is find a way
to write checks and there are these
things called scout programs where
venture capital firms
we have one give people uh checkbooks
to write on their behalf now they give
people checkbooks around the behalf to
people who've built a long-term
relationship with these venture capital
firms and have sent numerous deals this
is what i did at products on
i started sending all these deals to
ventures firms and over time they were
saying hey
this is inefficient you should just
write them directly you have good good
judgment you have good deal flow
you just do that so so you want to add
so much value such that they can't
ignore you and it just becomes more
efficient for them to
take a bet on you uh and then it goes
back to
building the asset building the reason
that you you have access for founders in
the first place
or why they want to take your money and
it could be something like products
or on deck or or some sort of product
that helps people get customers
recruit hire people get expertise but it
could also be an event series
a telegram group a podcast
there are all sorts of these little
different assets or products that that
you can build to
to get noticed and to get respected uh
you are a
very very big fan of rap everything from
uh the first company you started to
uh literally hosting zoom freestyle
battles
uh where did that love for hip-hop and
rap come from and then what is your
favorite instrumental
to uh wrap or freestyle over
when i was younger i wanted to make the
nba i had no
chance making the nba no i you know most
people give up that dream when they're
like
in third grade i was like in 10th grade
i was like i could still do it
i i was delusional i've always been
inspired by doing
uh i've inspired by agency just the
power to
to change your circumstances and i've
been inspired by the idea of doing
something that people think you have no
business doing
or don't have natural skill set doing
and showing them that you
through agency and hard work you can get
kind of good at something
and so rap i'd always been a a listener
and a fan
and so what i just said that the agency
combined with i was a very shy kid
in college i was in school in michigan
in detroit and
made my friends detroit and i sort of
saw people doing i said wow
i'm a really shy person but if i learned
how to do that
i bet i could public speak i bet i could
pitch i bet i could sell
i bet i would just be so much more
confident so much more outgoing
and plus it just looks like the most fun
fun thing ever
so i've been doing it for for you know
almost a
decade a bit over a decade and um you
know i'm not
like a pro or anything but you know i
could i could hold my own uh
in the in these zoom open mics and we
brought the open mic back so rapt fm
ended in 2014 we got the same crew that
we were wrapping with in 2013
seven years later you know some of them
were like 15 at the time another 22 33
on zoom every tuesday night and it's uh
it's been
you know enormous amount of fun in terms
of uh beat to to wrap over
um the uh nas state of mind is is just a
classic
um but uh drake has a lot of amazing
beats i mean
there's there's so much so much great
stuff out there i always joke i think
you're about the same age as i am
and uh we used to like run home and
watch mtv and like that some of the
early rap songs i remember was like
nelly's country grammar or nos like
illmatic
right like all all these things where
you're just like man that one or uh no
nas one mic
uh where like the breaking of the glass
and the police sirens and just
like for whatever reason man music just
makes you super nostalgia right when uh
when you listen to it uh what do you
think that or what do you wish that your
smartest friends were doing
more of today
i'm really inspired by people who um
who think in public um i'm i'm in some
of these private
uh group chats where uh there's i would
pay so much money
to be in them because i just learned so
much from them
and i sort of ask like why can't this be
on twitter like it used to be on twitter
um and um you know for some of them it's
for
job risk or whatever and it's
unfortunate that it is what it is
but i people benefit so much when when
when you think in public and you help
them sort of uh
you know think of ideas on their own or
they they take frameworks and build on
top of it i sometimes think
twitter is like a github for thinking
where people are constantly
putting building blocks out there that
inspires other people when it's not
civil war of course uh
it's sort of and so i wish some of the
smartest people or all these people were
having all these fascinating private
conversations
that they had them in public so that
other people can
can can learn and when we create the
systems that prevent
or sort of the cultural norms that
prevent people from having those
conversations
in private we don't republic we don't
see the loss we don't see the deadweight
loss but it but it's really powerful
paul graham had a post on this a few
years ago or maybe it was jessica
livingston the sound of silence
um and so that's uh that's something
that comes to mind because i've
benefited so much
from from people i i'd never met you who
now i'm friends with but for a decade i
was reading marginal revolution
and just hearing reading him think out
loud just gave me frameworks to think
about so many things inspired so many
thoughts and so i wish others did more
of that
it's a great answer in terms of
uh the political impact or political
instability there's lots of questions
around how does that impact vc how does
that
impact company building just talk a
little bit uh wherever you're
comfortable in terms of uh
how you foresee uh just the chaos that's
going on i think across the political
spectrum
and how that impacts some things around
tech and business building and investing
yeah i'm talking about
a couple frameworks i've been thinking
about recently which is
basically in sort of wealthy liberal
societies
there's this fundamental contradiction
between sort of the politics of safety
uh we want ourselves to be safe we want
you know murder rate to be low we want
you know people to to have comfort at
safety equality
and then at the same time we're
interested in sort of the extremity of
experiences our media and entertainment
is about like 50 shades of grey or
serial killer like we're so interested
in sort of this you know it's the uh
phenomenon where the car crash effect
we can't stop looking at the car crash
but we don't want to be in the car crash
and so the way that america solves that
problem in that contradiction it's kind
of interesting actually
it solves it at the level of virtual
reality but not
reality so an example of that is trump
you know i don't want to get too much
disrupt but it gives us sort of the
uh perception of an incipient fascist
regime without actually delivering on on
the fascist
so we're all sort of like larping that
we're in this fascist state
and similarly on the other side chaz and
all this
the stuff around the the sort of some of
the riots like seattle and protests
you you see videos and you're like wow
is this a maoist cultural revolution
no it's not a moscow it it's it's
larping it gives us the sort of
excitement of it without actually having
to suffer the consequences
and and there's some consequences don't
go wrong but it's
it's not what people suggest it isn't on
other side and the real way you tell is
by the body count like real
revolutionary real fascist regimes
communist regimes
have body counts in thousands millions
this is just in the in the low dozen and
most of the war takes place on twitter
and and twitter makes you think it's the
it's the french revolution
but but it's not even the worst of
cancer culture is a cakewalk
in comparison and so um in this sort of
crazy time
i i i came across this framework
recently of sort of
reality entrepreneurs um reality is sort
of up for grabs right now in a big way
and and what people refer to as
community building content creation like
what you do it that's a euphemism
it's it's sometimes it's literally
people defecting the shared sense of
mainstream reality that's existed for
centuries
and creating new ones and at the same
time that trust
in institutions in all institutions is
crumpled like who do you trust the who
the cdc
like the new york times who do you
listen to
it's it going back to individuals it's
it's people like yourself
it's people who are creating sort of
their own sort of realities and
communities and almost many cults
and and um and there's just a huge
opportunity right now
to uh to to do that and it's more
important than ever because
there's sort of this explosion of
information the explosive intensity
uh and so people are outsourcing their
sense making
to to these reality entrepreneurs and so
what does that mean
what does this all mean for investing
and uh
and startup stuff well one is any
startup that helps people navigate
uh uncertainty or ambiguity so
reality entrepreneurial individuals or
institutions or
uh just chaos i predict just more chaos
it's gonna get worse before it gets get
that's better
uh whether that's private security
whether that's uh you know
uh you know uh communities that that are
sort of covid
specific that help you do sort of the
equivalent of nba bubble uh but
in private i'm looking into that um
but then jesus sort of like almost new
religions and i don't mean religion and
sort of the belief in god but religion
is sort of like a community
that helps you make sense of what's
happening gives you a vision for the
future
and then gives you practices and rituals
around it and maybe the 1.0 version of
that was things like
soulcycle and barry bootcamp and um
you know daybreaker and all these sort
of communities but the next level is
going to be a bit more of a rebundling
of what we used to have
it's gonna look unlike anything we've
had before but
those are some some ideas i think that
you're dead on in terms of uh this like
rise of religions but the religions
aren't necessarily what you and i
consider religious
right there are kind of these other
things around community identity et
cetera
that uh that people just they don't
recognize them today as that but
i think in hindsight we'll see uh they
kind of replace religion
there's a lot of questions around
attributes and so
uh maybe the question to ask to kind of
answer the most
in the most succinct way is just what
are the best attributes on a founder
perspective what are the best attributes
that you see in
uh investors and then are those
attributes shared so if you are a great
founder you have certain attributes that
also make you a great investor and vice
versa or do you feel like there's
different attributes that make a great
investor and a great founder
i feel like they're significantly
different i think a lot of people make
the mistake
of saying i want to be a great investor
but i'm going to be a founder first to
figure out how to be a great investor
or i want to be a great founder but i'm
going to go work at a vc firm
and figure out how to be a great founder
often the best way to learn to do
something
is to do the thing directly so some
people believe this
but i i think you don't have to be a
great founder to be a great investor and
you certainly don't have to be an
investor
to be a founder they're they're
significantly different things operating
at different levels
of resolution one of my favorite things
uh in in investors is uh epistemological
modesty
sort of the knowledge of of what their
knowledge is about how much they
actually know about a about a topic
about a person
uh about about an opportunity um
and the answer is often not not as much
as you think
and so how can you shore up your your
weaknesses in those areas
and so what sort of systems and
processes can you build around it
i'm really interested in evolving this
concept of venture for something that is
just
just a craft to just something that is a
platform and a product and a business
and something
that isn't just sort of uh relying on
great man theory
but uh really just leverages networks so
i'm excited about investors that that
know how to do that that want to do that
and that might be different at different
stages certainly at sea i think i think
it's most important because it's
there's the least amount of data there
and it's also the widest aperture of
potential
opportunities from a founder perspective
i mean a lot of it is on founder market
fit right ev williams is the perfect
founder
to do twitter and medium and travis
kalanick is the perfect founder to do
uber and
cloud kitchens but travis would fail at
medium and ed would fail at
uber and so it's really just what's easy
for
it's this understanding of what's easy
for you to do but hard for others
and i look for founders that have unfair
uh advantages whether
it's key relationships key expertise or
just key sort of distinct
product sensibilities but then also one
general skill set from a founder is
really just ability to just zoom in and
out and so the zoom in is like
you know what's the perfect email to
send uh in
you know marketing copy or that converts
and here's why it doesn't convert and
really just get into the nitty-gritty
of the details and then an hour later
zoom out into
a board meeting and say hey here's how
we think about the next 12 months here's
what the fundraising landscape is
and to be able to communicate at that
level of resolution to
uh to your team is
inspires an immense amount of confidence
because it's very hard thing to do uh
the people who are doing the weeds
work won't be able to understand the the
long-term vision
but or the big picture but they'll
really appreciate it uh and the people
who are doing the big picture
uh you know won't really understand the
weed stuff but they will
really respect that that you understand
it so that that's a way to differentiate
uh accessing talent right one of the
things that you've done a
a great job of is on your podcast asking
over and over and over again many people
i've heard just
how do i find and identify great talent
what are the things that i think you've
learned from either asking that question
or doing it yourself
so yeah i have this this broader
philosophy of don't play the rat race
don't enter the rat race unless you're
the fastest rap
and so don't try to play tournament
level games
unless you could really win and i was
never an a
plus i never won the tournaments i
always said how can i make the game
unfair unfair advantage such that i can
do
even a b job and just you know win
easily
and so on the talent front keith boy
who's one of the mentors has this line
that peter
told him which is if you're a startup
you're gonna have to learn how to assess
talent better because um you're not
gonna be able to hire the same people
that facebook and google are hiring so
you're gonna have to
hire people who they wouldn't hire or
they wouldn't even think to go to or
they wouldn't think to go there
and and and work with them and have them
be
be fantastic i think that's very hard to
do so
the trick i've is basically on deck i i
want to
uh build relations with people over a
long period of time so i could see them
in action another hack i did is i
started this retreat where
basically i wrote a long list of all the
people i ever wanted to work with
and once you write that list most of
those people will be
unrecruitable they'll be starting a
company they'll be working at a company
they won't want to join
and what i did is i i started this
retreat i would do it three four times a
year and i would invite
all of them to retreat and lo and behold
you know three four years later i'm now
hiring a bunch of them
uh and and the trick there is it's one i
became regular
top of mind for them i i uh anytime they
were thinking about a career transition
i became the person that they
that they went to and you always with a
sort of a positive spirit like hey i'm
just going to put my friend hat on
what do you want to do next um and that
really inspires trust that you're
thinking about
them for the long term and then over
time
uh once we end up by introducing to each
other they became
friends they started build relationships
and then once we hired a few people in
that that retreat community
now a bunch of other people are just
sort of wanting to join
and so i think it's really just treating
recruiting as a
as a long-term game you know communities
aren't built overnight they take years
in advance
and same thing with with great teams
it's the relationships that you build in
advance and the structures
that allow you to build these
relationships with with a bunch of
people
uh over time so i normally ask
every guest the same two questions to
end it i'm gonna add a third because i
thought this was a fantastic question
that was sent in which is uh what is
your favorite
pre-podcast meal
the
you know i've really fallen in love with
english muffins with peanut butter
i mean it's it is what it is
it's just it just pumps me up what's
yours
uh i don't know if i have one single one
you know what actually uh living in new
york uh you end up ordering food a lot
for whatever reason just because it's so
so easy and uh there's like i don't know
four restaurants
and uh i was telling planet one time
that like it's pretty funny that we're
at the point now where we don't even
remember the names of the restaurants
sometimes we just know like oh we want
sushi okay like
just go in seamless and hit reorder
right you know you start getting into
this world of
um instant gratification which is
probably not a good thing
um but there's probably a rotation of
four i got like a greek meal there's a
sushi meal
uh maybe a couple others that uh that i
go on rotation
but i will say uh here's a good one for
you my brother when we were younger
uh pop-tarts he used to cook them in the
microwave
not in the toaster for whatever reason
and he used to walk around our house
telling us 17 seconds
17 seconds that that's the perfect
amount of time and so we still uh to
this day give him a hard time about that
amazing uh two questions to end it what
is the most important book
that you have ever read um
non-violent communication is a is a
really game-changing book
it's a communication framework not just
for conflict negotiation
but for day-to-day life they basically
think of it like a fork of english like
a modified version of english
that just maximizes the chances that
you're gonna
not make anyone defensive and you're
just going to say exactly what you mean
because you know sometimes you'll say
something and like is 99
what you mean and then one percent can
be interpreted differently or maybe as a
passive aggressive comment
and then people just focus on that one
percent uh this just makes sure
that your communication is super clear
so you're getting across what you want
to say
but then nothing else extra that is
likely to make them defensive that
that's been a total game changer
i recommend it to people i love that
book um
aliens believer or non-believer i
am a believer i don't know how one could
not not be a believer
i the bigger question is is uh you know
do
do we know their existence do they know
of our existence one thing i'm really
curious about
is why you know it came out in the new
york times recently that
uh there are some files that they're now
opening why have
the us government tried to hide this
from us because
and i i think they're just trying to
prevent commotion or chaos but i
actually think we need this
you know there's this saying you know me
uh me against my brother
me and my brother against my cousin me
and my brother and my cousin
against the neighboring family so it
just goes to show like
we're gonna have conflict and i ideally
it could be at the highest level
resolution possible
so we can go here and as we're having
this conversation
you know there's never been more sort of
internal chaos in our country
that since i've been alive um
we need a common enemy and ideal you
know ideally like
aliens would be way better than china
and so i say
release the information on you know
there's this great uh quote by jonathan
height has this concept called asteroid
club which is if an asteroid was coming
to earth in the next two weeks we would
we would just stop all of our conflicts
and just focus on how to
how to prevent this and we would all
cohere and so
i wonder if something similar could
happen around aliens while you were
talking i was literally thinking yeah
like
we have the common enemy of china but
but definitely agree that aliens would
be much better
so all humans can uh can come together
rather than uh
just be uh imaginary lines and uh in a
map
um you could ask me one question to end
it what do you got for me
yeah i uh i had a couple if you don't
mind so
covid could be the opportunity for for
crypto i mean you know
trust in institutions is an all-time low
uh and so
what is script all about it's all about
trust trust right so uh
governments have shown that they're
incompetent so it's an opportunity for
charter cities
the media has shown that it's sort of
cynical or can't really predict
uh what's happening and won't even admit
it so it's an opportunity for prediction
markets
and then we've shown that we'll just
print our way through anything and so
that's the opportunity for bitcoin
how do you sort of think about the game
plan
or the opportunity for crypto in a
postcode world that's one question the
second question
is sometimes i advise people to take the
pomp for x career path
you know you you made a name among other
things just going
asymmetric risk on bitcoin you just you
know there's this quote of
i fear not the person who said you know
a thousand different things
uh but said the same thing a thousand
different times a bruce lee modified
quote and
that's you with bitcoin you were really
early on that and made a big bet on it
and it really paid off for you
and so what are other spaces that people
can do that and how do they sort of be
the
the pomp for x i see your your brother
doing that in sports and he's doing it
phenomenally
um so crypto in a postcode moment and
then
uh pomp for x opportunities and what
advice do you have for people who are
looking to take your path
in different spaces yeah so crypto i
think
uh is this weird thing where everyone
wants to tap in now
right and you know i'm always kind of
careful now to say like bitcoin is a
multi-decade
type thing if it fully fulfills the
promise of kind of
next global reserve currency et cetera
and you know people here multi-decade
they're like oh yeah
yeah sure like i'm down for that i'm
like no no just so we're clear that's
like 30 plus years
right like like that's a really really
long time horizon uh and just humans are
really bad at
you know there's the bill gates quote of
like we overestimate one year under
estimate 10. now bring that out to like
30 years and it's you know very hard to
kind of predict where we're going to be
and also have the patience to to do that
um so i think that uh when you kind of
zoom out you look at where
are we it's like actually like we're way
ahead i think of where most people
thought we would be at this point
um and now you've got this like macro
tailwind uh
right into a having there's probably
gonna be this you know really big price
um kind of upward movement uh in the
next 18 months and what's interesting to
me is like pretty much every time this
has happened in the past
there wasn't a lot of people paying
attention like the last one kind of
brought people's attention right in 2017
where like the media started being like
wait a minute like this thing is
actually going
to twenty thousand dollars like that's
insane and you saw kind of articles and
you saw the icos and kind of all of that
you know
hype and excitement uh if it happens
again like i think it's gonna happen
now it's like everyone's already paying
attention right and so it's just going
to be that on steroids which
uh you know there'll be a lot of bad
parts to that but but i think um
really kind of thrust it onto a global
main stage so that'll be interesting
um i definitely agree with this idea of
like crypto and post uh
covid world being essential like i talk
a lot about like centralization now is
becoming a business risk
so whether you look at it like you know
tick tock being potentially banned from
the united states
all the way to just trusting you know do
you trust the cloud providers with your
data
all that kind of stuff um figuring out
how to be
efficient and decentralized uh is going
to be hard for a lot of people
um across the the technology stack but i
think that's just going to become a
a necessity one thing on that real quick
is fascinating you know
the conversation a few years ago and
chris dixon had his post of why
decentralization matters
it was really focused on sort of the the
zynga facebook use case
which is the platform risk as a company
you take on somebody else's platform or
a user when you don't own your own data
and it was really this this risk that
the platform would screw the user
and it's so interesting because now
we're in sort of the era of cancer
culture
we're seeing platforms want to
decentralize themselves
to not have a risk the user rooting
their brand
and so it's like now they exceed
responsibility a little bit
and from having to make a really tough
you know editorial decision or being
you know uh sort of motivated by the mob
and so i think that that is fascinating
transition
yeah and look i actually think just like
bitcoin is kind of different things to
different people same thing here
decentralization serves like different
benefits to different people as well
right so it's always like we like to put
things in a box and say like oh
it's because this is why this is
valuable but at the end of the day these
are like very complex systems
so i think generally like that's the
trend and it'll only accelerate it won't
uh kind of
uh retract at all uh in terms of the
pomp forex i think it's first of all
hilarious that you uh you call it that
um i i really do agree
with this idea of like taking a early
bet
on something that you truly believe in
like like if you're not authentic about
it then
you know you're dead on day one um but
there is this benefit
uh that i had obviously with bitcoin
kind of you know going the way that it
went
uh other people have done this in
certain verticals uh my brother's
definitely a great example i think of
just
um you know i joke with him all the time
like what he's doing is not necessarily
new
like darren rovell did this 25 years ago
it's just that like
you and me are probably on the lower end
of the generation that remembers
darren rovell right when he's at espn
and kind of all this stuff
but like some of the stories that my
brother will tell like literally darren
will like
you know tweet out and be like i told a
story 18 years ago right
you know i've written this article three
times and so
it goes back to like it's not
necessarily just like having to do
something new as much as
it's like having a very specific focus
telling people like this is what i'm
going to do
so i'm going to cover the you know in
his case the money and business behind
sports
and then just drive at it every single
day and just like can i just like beat
people over the head with it
right and what you almost end up doing
is um who is it superhuman i think did a
great job with this early on where they
were like
i don't want as many users as possible i
want the right users
like that's basically what you do with
that repetition is you end up like
getting rid of everyone who was kind of
like a half fan
and you just get the people who like
they can't you know soak up enough of
the content
uh and that really builds kind of
engagement and distribution all that
kind of stuff
other areas i think it's interesting um
so
one definitely an education i think
there's gonna be this massive uh
kind of um resurgence of all kinds of
education so you're talking about like
you know
what does a digital first kind of
university look like
you can basically take every single
subject that you would have in high
school or in college
and somebody's gonna be that person
teaching millions of people on the
internet
right and that historically like it was
kind of cheesy if someone was like oh
like i have a youtube
show and i teach people american history
like nobody really cared
but actually that can be built into a
massive business now because the tools
um and software are in place where you
can do everything from subscriptions to
advertising to physical products to
you know virtual events like all that
kind of stuff and so
i think just go through your high school
like
curriculum and every single course will
turn into a business
another area i'm fascinated by is uh
the all of the technology verticals that
benefit from
taking supply chains and manufacturing
facilities and bringing them back on
shore
so if you've got to bring you know your
manufacturing or supply chain back
uh you can't use american labor because
the cost is too high it becomes cost
prohibitive so you've got to use
technology
so there's like this resurgence of 3d
manufacturing
you know 3d printing um all kinds of
things around just robotics and
automation
whatever um i think that's an area
that we all kind of know is like it's
cool it's gonna be a thing
i couldn't tell you the first thing
about it and so like if i knew that
there was a person who was like
that's the 3d printing guy right or or
that's the 3d manufacturing woman
like you just naturally gravitate
towards them if that's what you want to
learn about and so you can kind of own
entire verticals like that
uh and then the last thing um is
i don't have enough thoughts to know
what the answer is but an
area that i think is really interesting
is creativity
and so creativity kind of cuts across
all industries like you you want
somebody who is creative
but school's like the last place to
teach you how to be creative
right and so like i don't know yet know
what the solution is like is it just
some like
revamped version of like an educational
you know uh situation where like i'm a
teacher you're all on zoom and i teach
you how to be creative
probably not but there's got to be
something that people can do
to like how do i drastically pull you up
the
creative like spectrum or curve so that
you engage with this product this you
know service whatever it is
and now you feel like you've become way
more creative
my guess being that that's one of the
most viral businesses in the world as
well
because if all of a sudden you start
talking to me at a party and i'm like
dude that guy's super creative oh yeah i
took this course
right like it's something that like
people want to brag about because
creativity
in our society is still uh put on a
pedestal to some degree as well
right like it's like oh you're wealthy
or like you're an
artist to some degree with your musician
like a physical artist whatever like we
still hold that in high regard
um and so i don't you know first of all
if you have ideas or if anyone listening
has ideas would love to hear them but
but i think that that's like the other
area
uh that's really interesting because
again it's also the thing that is the
farthest away from being disrupted by
automation machines et cetera right it
is it's got kind of this like inherent
moat
that uh we at least like to believe that
we are uh you know
the most creative animals but after uh
gbt3 or whatever
maybe not i think part of it is just
doing it evolve this old tweet of
the desire to it's not the desi it's not
the education that is scarce it's a
desire to learn
uh and and similarly with with projects
uh and that's what you know on deck is
really trying to have
project based cohorts where you've said
you wanted to have a podcast for a long
time you said you went to a youtube
channel you said you wanted to do
uh a startup you said you want to start
angel investing what are all the
bottlenecks
that prevented you from doing it here's
where that stops like you are going to
start you are going to ship something
you're just going to start start trying
it and then just your point on on pump
for x
or our point on it it's never been a
better time
to be a creator in terms of monetizing
even stuff that's come out in the last
few weeks like
the the rolling funds i think is is game
changing if you have an audience
based on your writing or you have a
course one if you have a right if you
have an audience you're writing you can
start a course you can make money off
that
then you can also people trust your
judgment you can start a fun and invest
in people that you're
that you're you're seeing or starting
and so i'm seeing a lot of creators
pursue that path
and uh and and it's very exciting
listen you're welcome whenever you want
i'll do this forever with you
uh where can we find you on the internet
find out more about global
uh or villas global and also uh on deck
uh village global.vcbondeck.com follow
me on twitter eric thornberg
uh pump when i talk about personal
emotes your name comes up because
to reverse engineer what you've built
over the past few years
is is immensely difficult mad respect uh
it's a
pleasure to know you'd be your friend uh
i'm uh stoked you had me on the show
thanks a lot you're uh you're way too
kind my friend we'll do it again soon
awesome okay